[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
guten abend in einen rammstein bzw
rammstein die größte basis der us
airforce außerhalb des eigenen landes
wirkt aktuell wie eine afghanische
kleinstadt insgesamt mehrere zehntausend
menschen die aus afghanistan ausgeflogen
wurden sollen von dort weiter reisen in
die usa über 11.000 warten noch darauf
rammstein ist heute auch politisches
zentrum all derer die händeringend
suchen nach einer tragfähigen lösung für
die wartenden für die die nach wie vor
dringend raus wollen aus afghanistan und
für alle die vor ort vom hunger bedroht
sind der westen die außenminister
deutschlands und der usa haben einiges
gutzumachen andrea maurer berichtet
eine aus kabul gerettete familie
empfängt den amerikanischen
außenminister auf dem
us-luftwaffenstützpunkt ramstein
evakuierungs drehkreuz der amerikaner
11.200 menschen warten hier derzeit auf
weiterreise dass rund 90 personen jetzt
in deutschland asylantrag gestellt haben
überschattet das anschließende treffen
mit dem deutschen außenminister
es ist richtig dass es hier auf der base
in ramstein
asylanträge gibt will noch einmal
deutlich sagen es handelt sich aber in
der anzahl um weniger als ein prozent
der menschen die er gebracht worden sind
wir arbeiten mit unseren amerikanischen
partnern außerordentlich eng zusammen
wir konferieren jeden tag wir haben
klare verabredungen geschlossen wie
lange die menschen hier sich aufhalten
können
verabredet ist dass die evakuierten
maximal zehn tage auf deutschem boden
bleiben die airbase nicht verlassen
kontakt zu deutschen behörden gibt es
nicht die asylanträge seien wohl über
dritte gestellt worden heißt es aus
sicherheitskreisen
sie müssen sich vorstellen insgesamt
34.000 menschen haben die amerikaner
allein über ramstein ausgeflogen und
deswegen wird es tatsächlich
möglichkeiten geben unter umständen auch
weil personen aus der verwandtschaft aus
der familie bereits in deutschland leben
solche anträge stellen zu können in
ramstein waren heute auch 20 weitere
außenminister per videokonferenz
zugeschaltet es ging vor allem um den
internationalen umgang mit der neuen
taliban-regierung die ausschließlich aus
mitgliedern der islamistischen miliz
besteht
römischer betreiber wir verstehen diese
regierung als übergangsregierung wir
werden sie an ihren taten messen
eine diplomatische anerkennung schließt
der deutsche außenminister aus das sei
aber weniger die frage als eine klare
haltung sagt die opposition
die anerkennung einer regierung ist
völkerrechtlich relativ einfach indem
sie mit der regierung reden
erkennen sie an dass sie die de facto
kontrolle über das territorium hat
insofern hat es diese anerkennung schon
mindestens mit dem abkommen von doha vom
februar 2020 gegeben wichtig ist
allerdings dass wir klar machen dass wir
keine hilfen geben dass wir keine
formelle aufwertung dieser regierung
machen sondern dass wir von ihr
verlangen dass sie bestimmte
grundlegende standards einhält die welt
schaue genau hin diese botschaft senden
der deutsche und der amerikanische
außenminister heute aus kabul senden
frauen diese bilder an die welt offener
mutiger protest gegen die neue regierung
der keine einzige frau angehört
und bei uns ist jetzt der
bundesaußenminister und heiko maas hallo
josi was er mag es nachdem sie
überrascht wurden überrollt wurden vom
vormarsch der taliban entsetzt waren
haben sie jetzt heute eine klare
vorstellung davon wie sie den menschen
in afghanistan noch helfen können die in
höchster gefahr schweben und nicht
evakuiert wurden bislang ja wir haben
auch gar keine zeit noch weiter wunden
zu lecken sondern und darüber haben wir
heute mit über 20 außenministern
gesprochen zusammen mit toni blick in
dem amerikanischen außenminister was
sind jetzt die voraussetzungen dafür um
mit den taliban und der neuen regierung
selbstgespräche zu führen was die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir über den
flughafen weiter eigene staatsbürger
evakuieren können der flughafen wird
wieder betrieben und die nächste woche
möglicherweise auch für weitere
evakuierungsflüge und wie können
menschen über den landweg afghanistan
verlassen etwa in den nachbarländern
nach pakistan herr massieren von
gesprächen sie sprechen von commitment
der taliban jetzt hat die taliban haben
eine regierung ein regierungspersonal
vorgestellt bei dem es ihnen doch
eigentlich draußen muss 33 posten alles
männer viele von denen waren an der
macht während der letzten
schreckensherrschaft das einzig
auffindbare foto vom neuen taliban
innenminister stammt vom fbi
fahndungsplakat jetzt muss man ihn nicht
mehr fanden er sitzt im innenministerium
und zwar im ministerbüro sind dass die
leute mit denen sie in irgendeiner form
zusammen arbeiten können
die frage ist wozu ist es notwendig und
das was wir wissen was auch die
vereinten nationen sagen ist dass
afghanistan vor einer hungersnot steht
dass der nächste winter bevorsteht und
das wenn das chaos anhält die menschen
dort verhungern werden und ich finde ja
dann muss die internationale
staatengemeinschaft auch bereit sein mit
solchen die man nicht mag oder die
möglicherweise auch aus der
vergangenheit bis in die gegenwart mit
inakzeptablen dingen aufgefallen sind
aber wenn es darum geht den hungertod
von menschen zu verhindern
wenn wir humanitäre hilfe ins land
bringen wollen und dass davon abhängig
ist dass die taliban diese humanitäre
hilfe nahrungsmittel auch ins land
lassen dann finde ich im interesse der
menschen in afghanistan muss es möglich
sein auch gespräche zu führen auch wenn
es einem schwer also der zweck heiligt
die mittel so zu sagen aber welche
sicherheit haben sie denn das wohl hin
zu bewahren finde ich ist das etwas mehr
als nur der zweck heiligt die mittel
sondern dann ist das etwas was zur
humanitären verantwortung für uns alle
aber führt das denn zu irgendetwas also
können sie sich tatsächlich darauf
verlassen dass die neuen machthaber in
kabul ihnen da versprechen mögen ich
muss nochmal auf den neuen innenminister
zurückkommen der gilt als drahtzieher
des anschlags auf die deutsche botschaft
kabul im mai 2017 mit 150 toten also in
den letzten tage und in den letzten
wochen haben wir eine vielzahl von
statements der taliban aus kabul oder
auch ausdauer gehört mit vielen
moderaten tönen auf die worte wollen wir
uns nicht verlassen sondern auch die
taten die regierung die jetzt gebildet
wurde
bildet ja nicht alle gesellschaftliche
gruppen in afghanistan ab vielleicht der
einzelnen taliban-gruppen es soll noch
weitere regierungsmitglieder folgen das
wird man sehen ob das tatsächlich ein
abbild afghanischen gesellschaft ist
oder ob das eine reine taliban regierung
ist und wenn es um die einhaltung von
menschenrechten geht frauenrechten und
wenn es darum geht das was die teile
waren schon zugesagt haben nämlich dass
ausländer weiter ausweisen können aber
auch unsere kräfte daran wird man sie
messen ganz sicherlich nicht nur das was
auf pressekonferenzen oder in
schriftlichen statements verbreitet
wurde
sie haben ihre situation herr maas
gerade ganz gut beschrieben das ist ja
eine zwickmühle den verfolgten helfen
und dabei zusammenarbeiten müssen mit
den verfolgern und das ist aber alles ja
eine situation in der die westliche welt
auch durch eigene fehleinschätzung
geraten ist überhaupt auch bei ihnen
tauchen jetzt neue vorwürfe auf dass sie
schon viel früher wussten oder hätten
wissen können dass die taliban kabul
erstürmen würden nämlich durch einen
sogenannten draht bericht ihrer
botschafterin in washington sie haben
selbst gesagt wir müssen alles auf
bereiten wir müssen auch konsequenzen
ziehen wann geht das los dann erhält man
das findet der stadt ansonsten würden
sie mehr solche fragen nicht stellen
natürlich gab es aus den usa hinweise
dass sich die lage verschlechtert diese
hinweise hatten wir auch das auch vom
amtierenden in washington und dann haben
sie aber noch mal sieben tage gewartet
bis es überhaupt losging mit
vorbereitungs von zudem das stimmt ja so
nicht wir haben schon anfang august
bevor dieser bericht überhaupt kam den
evakuierungsplan unsere botschaft
aktualisiert und erst drei tage nachdem
dieser bericht kam dann auch scharf
gestellt worden wir sind mit den
amerikanern immer in einem sehr engen
austausch gewesen und nachdem der
evakuierungs beschluss der amerikaner
gefasst wurde das in drei stunden
evakuiert wird ist in wenigen minuten
dass auch in der deutschen botschaft
geschehen und die deutschen
botschaftsmitarbeiter sind genauso wie
die mitarbeiter anderer internationaler
botschaften mit den amerikanern von dem
botschaftsgelände auf den flughafen
evakuiert wurden und deshalb ja die
dinge haben sich dramatisiert und nicht
alles ist im voraus gesehen worden das
hat mir mein amerikanischer kollege
heute in ramstein noch einmal bestätigt
aber die deutschen mitarbeiter der
botschaft sind genauso evakuiert worden
auch im gleichen zeitlichen zusammenhang
die mitarbeiter anderer botschaften und
hieraus ergibt sich doch das dass das
nicht in der weise bei uns der fall
gewesen ist dass wir später als andere
dran gewesen sind dass man das sind sich
so ähnlich oder auf eigentlich genauso
auch schon häufiger gesagt in der
vergangenheit sie haben selbst
angekündigt dass ich auch eigene
schlüsse für sich selbst ganz persönlich
ziehen wollen das klingt jetzt noch
nicht so als seien sie da einen schritt
weitergekommen ich habe mich glaube ich
was anderes gefragt gerade und dabei
geht es darum mal klarzustellen wie die
fakten sind und dass ich immer dasselbe
soll hängt damit zusammen dass die
fakten halt so sind die verändern sich
eben nicht natürlich muss das
aufgearbeitet werden und im moment und
deshalb treffen wir uns von haben uns
heute getroffen mit über 20
außenminister geht es darum dafür zu
sorgen dass wir unsere staatsbürger aus
afghanistan raus bekommen und unsere
ortskräfte das ist eine aufgabe da
fühlen wir uns alle verpflichteten der
kommen wir auch jetzt nach und es geht
nicht nur für uns es gilt auch für die
anderen staaten denn die fehler die
sicherlich bei uns gemacht worden sind
die sind in anderen staaten genauso
gemacht wurden sagt heiko maas der
bundesaußenminister ich danke ihnen für
das gespräch sehr gerne
und das gespräch aber aus termingründen
vor der sendung aufgezeichnet im
auslandsjournal gleich nach und nehmen
wir sie mit auf die straßen von kabul
sind dramatische bilder von wut und
widerstand gegen die taliban
aufgebrachte frauen gegen bewaffnete
kämpfer gleich im auslandsjournal aber
erst nach deutschland angesichts der
stockenden deutschen impfkampagne hat
berlins landesregierung jetzt quasi die
weiße fahne gehisst auf dem roten
rathaus
vielleicht haben wir das was wir machen
können als politik ausgereizt sagt der
regierende bürgermeister michael müller
haben er sehe keinen sinn mehr darin
sich mit einem dritten oder vierten
brief an die berliner zu wenden da hat
er möglicherweise recht diese briefe
dürften mehrheitlich im papierkorb
landen gleichwohl klingt das doch sehr
nach kapitulation
angesichts einer lage in der aufgeben
eigentlich keine option sein sollte das
hier ist die aktuelle impfquote in
deutschland
61,6 prozent hinten liegen vor allem die
ostdeutschen länder das reicht so nicht
für den herbst und winter da sind sich
die experten einig die bundesregierung
will ab montag eine aktionswoche starten
wie so etwas aussehen kann zeigt zu den
ricken jetzt am beispiel hamburg es mag
zufall sein aber eines von hamburgs
mobilen impf teams war heute in der
erlöserkirche zu besuch die hoffnung
dass das virus den alltag nicht mehr
bestimmt sie äußerte sich in einer
langen schlange vor dem gemeindehaus
alle hier hatten mit der impfung lange
gewartet bis sie ihnen buchstäblich vor
die füße fiel nun gibt es sicher noch
einige die also bewusst sich dagegen
entscheiden aber eben doch noch einige
die auch sagen das passte bisher einfach
nicht gut oder ist schlichtweg
überfordert mich auch in der
organisation und da denke ich jeder
kleine beitrag ein guter beitrag die
hansestadt zieht ihre joker im kampf um
weitere 11 prozent der hsv und st pauli
stadien und die elbphilharmonie
der große konzertsaal als ruheraum der
erfolg überschaubar leuchttürme alleine
reichen anscheinend nicht schon gar
nicht um die zu erreichen die ohnehin
durch viele raster fallen was auf der
einen seite der frage der zeit und auf
der anderen seite die frage des
niedrigschwelligen angebotes wir müssen
hier anreize setzen und wir müssen
schauen dass wir hier ganz viel
motivationsschub noch in verschiedene
bevölkerungsgruppen hineintragen können
also doch mehr druck hamburg schenkt und
nimmt freiheit an der großen freiheit
und den anderen vergnügungsviertel
zutritt nur für geimpfte und genießen
gäste zweig als das modell die abende
sind ausgelassen und voll die
ungeimpften freunde daheim sind
plötzlich weit weg und deswegen kommen
mehrere dinge zusammen am ende auch
natürlich der anreiz vielleicht doch die
impfung in betracht zu ziehen weil dann
das leben wieder normal ablaufen kann
und man eben auch diese zweite option
mit nutzen kann 2g 3g die betriebe
können täglich wechseln die regelung für
drinnen und draußen das muss ein
gastwirt mit seinem personal erst mal
kontrollieren und schon findet die
polizei einen nur getesteten zwischen
geimpften
genießen man muss immer sehen die
kontakt beschränkungen fallen jetzt weg
das heißt also es sind viel mehr leute
viel enger zusammen und wenn wir dort
jemand haben der sich ansteckt dann
haben die nächste infektionskette die
ersten beiden wochen mit dem zweig
modell haben der hansestadt viel
aufmerksamkeit beschert aber auch eine
diskussion um ausschluss und druck wir
müssen uns irgendwie langsam alle
kämpfen also es muss einfach wieder zu
kommen und das ist wahrscheinlich
einfach die einzige methode das ist
quasi
demokratisch zu machen ohne die leute
wirklich zu zwingen von den nicht
geimpften ist ein bisschen eine blöde
situation
muss jeder für sich entscheiden um das
angebot jedenfalls ist da diese woche
sind die impf teams in hamburgs
gotteshäusern unterwegs in allen
übrigens den wochenabschluss übernehmen
die moscheen der stadt
gibt die berliner landespolitik jetzt
auf in sachen impfkampagne im
heute-journal update hat man guckte mir
einige fragen an berlins regierenden
bürgermeister und hier jetzt unser
nächstes thema heute abend viel
aufgewühlte erinnerung schmerz und wut
ein mammut prozess beginnt heute in
paris um eine terror nacht vor fast
sechs jahren die sich in europas
gedächtnis eingegraben hat das stade de
france mehrere restaurants und bars die
konzerthalle pater klar diese orte zu
erwähnen reicht schon und wir alle sehen
die bilder wieder vor uns jetzt ist die
justiz an der reihe um recht zu sprechen
und bestenfalls auch um wunden zu heilen
1800 nebenkläger 330 anwälte und ein
trotziger hauptangeklagte aus paris
berichtet anna rennt nach den attentaten
wollte er nur noch weg aus paris claude
immanuel triumph erlebte überlebte die
terror nacht in einer bar unweit des
konzerthauses peter kloo er wurde schwer
verletzt in dem prozess der heute
gestartet ist wird er als nebenkläger
auftreten
für mich ist die wichtigste person die
dort sein wird salopp des lahm möchte
ich entgegen treten mit ihm reden auch
wenn ich nicht weiß ob er antworten wird
antworten kann antworten will
salah abdel slum hauptangeklagte
einziger überlebender der terrorzelle
und kämpfer des islamischen staates wie
er gleich zu beginn des prozesses
erklärt der unter großen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
stattfindet sein auftreten reißt die
wunden wieder auf
klaas von jungen eine solche aussage zu
hören das empfinden meine mandanten als
eine erneute direkte bedrohung das war
eine sehr schlimme erfahrung gleich zu
beginn aber so wird es wohl die nächsten
neun monate weitergehen
erinnerungen an den terror der die stadt
dort traf wo das leben pulsiert im
konzertsaal peter kloo richteten die
attentäter ein blutbad an feuerten auf
gäste die auf den terrassen der bars und
restaurants saßen sprengten sich vor dem
fußballstadion in die luft während
frankreich gegen deutschland spielte
unter den zuschauern auch der damalige
französische präsident die sorge vor
einem anschlag war schon damals
großer klub wir wussten dass es in
racker in syrien den islamischen staat
gab der dieses territorium kontrollierte
und einzelpersonen darauf vorbereitet
hat sie nach europa zu schicken um dort
angriffe durchzuführen welche
information uns gefehlt hat war wann wo
und wer
nicht nur die nebenkläger das ganze land
hofft nun auf antworten auch auf die
frage ob und welche fehler geheimdienste
und andere behörden gemacht haben das
töten hätte verhindert werden können
die angriffe haben uns als nation tief
getroffen es waren viele menschen
betroffen es gab viele tote und
verwundete gut dass nun für
gerechtigkeit gesorgt hat
das verfahren macht deutlich dass
frankreich nicht vergisst unser land ist
weiter da um den terrorismus zu
bekämpfen weltweit und in frankreich um
die stärke von justiz und demokratie
gegenüber terror und barbarei auch darum
geht es in dem prozess der schon jetzt
als historisch bezeichnet wird
und wir bleiben noch einen moment beim
thema und in paris mit gundula zum
auftakt seines besuchs in paris hat
unions kanzlerkandidat laschet der opfer
der terroranschläge dort gedacht vor den
bug long legte er blumen nieder bevor er
von präsident marc empfangen wurden
thema im elysée palast war ein
gemeinsames europäisches
sicherheitssystem um
grenzüberschreitenden extremismus und
terror zu bekämpfen
laschet war offiziell in seiner funktion
als deutsch französische kultur
bevollmächtigter in paris am montag
hatte spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz mit
makro gesprochen in nordrhein westfalen
soll die flutkatastrophe mit einem
untersuchungsausschuss aufgearbeitet
werden spd und grüne beantragten den
ausschuss um zu klären ob bei dem
hochwasser mitte juli mehr menschenleben
hätten gerettet werden können der
landtag in düsseldorf gedachte der
insgesamt 57 menschen die in nordrhein
westfalen durch die flut oder an den
folgen der katastrophe gestorben sind
rheinland pfalz zählt mehr als 140
todesopfer das bundeskabinett hat eine
neue strategie zur cybersicherheit für
die nächsten fünf jahre beschlossen
dabei geht es um den schutz von behörden
von kritischer infrastruktur unternehmen
und bürgern die bundesregierung weist in
dem papier auf die gestiegene bedrohung
durch cyber attacken hin
die räumung der baumhäuser im hambacher
forst durch die stadt kerpen im herbst
2008 10 war rechtswidrig so ein urteil
des verwaltungsgerichts köln gegen das
noch berufung eingelegt werden kann das
gericht entschied die damals als
begründung genannten
brandschutzvorschriften sei nur
vorgeschoben gewesen tatsächlich sei es
um die entfernung der braunkohle gegner
gegangen rwe hatte den wald für den
kohleabbau wohnen lassen wollen wegen
des kohle ausstiegs ist der plan vom
tisch
das klang nach einer echten änderung der
geschäftsgrundlage die welt beschließt
eine globale mindeststeuer von 15
prozent damit gerade digitale
großkonzerne wie google facebook amazon
die auch in deutschland millionen
gewinne machen auch in deutschland
adäquat besteuert werden das ganze ist
ein lieblingsprojekt von
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz und es
wirkt nur offenbar anders als gedacht
nach recherchen des zdf magazins frontal
bekommt deutschland von der neuen
mindestbesteuerung der tech giganten de
facto kaum etwas ab armin coerper hat
die details
das ist einer der top gewinner der
pandemie der streaming dienst netflix
elf millionen abonnements in deutschland
allein hier macht netflix pro jahr eine
milliarde euro umsatz die gewinne aber
fließen fast unversteuert über die
niederlande in die usa wo die
firmenzentrale an der westküste sitzt
die hier ansässigen tech giganten sind
die wertvollsten unternehmen der welt
sie hat der deutsche finanzminister ins
visier genommen als er im juli beim
g20-gipfel in venedig einen durchbruch
verkündet
immer angebracht sehr vorsichtig zu
sagen
das wort zu verwenden das etwas
geschichtliches aber in diesem moment
glaube ich schon dass das ein großer
geschichtlicher im moment ist historisch
am ergebnis von venedig unternehmen
werden weltweit mit einer mindeststeuer
von 15 prozent belegt das soll
steueroasen austrocknen
das zdf magazin frontal hat exklusiv
steuerexperten mit der berechnung
beauftragt was die reform deutschland
bringt ergebnis mit insgesamt rund einer
milliarde euro jährlich weniger als
erhofft netflix zum beispiel würde statt
bisher 0,2 in zukunft 0,3 prozent
steuern zahlen google statt 3,6 in
zukunft 7,3 prozent weil sie gewinne
weiterhin an ihre firmensitze
verschieben können in länder die trotz
mindeststeuer günstiger sind als
deutschland das
bundesfinanzministerium und herr scholz
feiern sich jetzt für diesen sieg
allerdings
dieser kampf gegen die steuer sind diese
sieg gegen die steueroasen die folge
dass die gerechte besteuerung der
digital konzerne in den hintergrund
getreten ist die digital konzerne
verschieben nach wie vor ihre gewinne
aus deutschland raus jetzt nicht mehr
auf die bermudas sondern in die usa auch
die opposition sieht in scholz
vermeintlichen durchbruch keinen großen
wurf herr scholz hat versucht ein so
ambitionslose kompromiss zu finden
dass auch facebook beifall geklatscht
hat und dass er keinem wehtut
kanzlerkandidat scholz steht für ein
angefragt das interview nicht zur
verfügung bei einem wahlkampfauftritt
konfrontieren beten mit den berechnungen
bin überzeugt dass da einige nicht
vollständig gerechnet haben weil sie
sich die steuerreform die wir gerade auf
den weg gebracht haben und bringen
werden nicht vollständig angeschaut
haben in diesem fall haben wir
tatsächlich nach der besten datenlage
berechnet und nichts vergessen also
dieser vorwurf ist tatsächlich einfach
falsch
tatsächlich schreibt uns netflix auf
anfrage wir unterstützen die pläne 15
mindeststeuer sind für den konzern wohl
verschmerzbar und die gewinne können
weiterhin von deutschland in die
steuerlich günstigeren usa fließen
wir bleiben beim lieben geld noch mal
laden die korona krise belastet auch die
europäischen banken die ezb
bankenaufsicht mahnt aktuell durch die
pandemie drohe sich die lage der
geldhäuser zu verschlechtern die
probleme würden durch die
außergewöhnlichen staatlichen
hilfsmaßnahmen verschleiert frank
bethmann die herausforderungen der
banken waren auch thema auf einem
branchengipfel heute in frankfurt ja als
wären die probleme nicht bereits groß
genug europas banken droht eine weitere
gefahr zu viele kreditausfälle in
nächster zeit durch eine welle von
firmenpleiten
ungewöhnlich deutlich legten
bankenaufseher heute den finger in die
wunde wohl auch weil sie wissen viele
europäische geldhäuser sind schwach auf
der brust die britische hsbc europas
grösste bank gehört gewiss nicht dazu
doch selbst sie kann nach
marktkapitalisierung längst nicht mehr
mithalten mit den großen us häusern
allen voran jp morgan chase die deutsche
bank dagegen mit 22 milliarden euro
börsenwert fast schon wie ein winzling
diese zahlen vergleiche sind ist die den
bedeutungsverlust heimischer banken
aufzeigen während die usa ihre
geldinstitute nach der globalen
finanzkrise gestärkt haben wurden in
europa nach den exzessen die banken an
die leine gelegt auf dem branchentreff
des handelsblattes heute appelle für ein
umdenken
ohne starke banken werde sich europa so
deutsche-bank-chef seligen in einer
polarisierten weltwirtschaft zwischen
den usa und china nicht behaupten können
es ist ein schmaler grat auf dem die
politik und aufsichtsbehörden da wandeln
einerseits will man nie wieder banken
mit steuer-milliarden retten müssen
andererseits braucht die europäische
wirtschaft tatsächlich eine starke
finanz branche um unabhängig zu bleiben
frank bethmann vielen dank für die
einordnung
im hamburger hafen hat am abend das
weltgrößte containerschiff angelegt die
400 meter lange und über 60 meter breite
airways kann fast 24.000
standardcontainer aufnehmen das
riesenschiff wurde erst im juli
fertiggestellt und ist gerade auf
jungfernfahrt rund um die welt ein
viertel der ladung soll bis samstag
umgeschlagen werden dann verlässt der
gigant wieder hamburg
gleich zum sport hier zunächst die
gewinnzahlen vom lotto am mittwoch ohne
gewähr 13 21 23 30 41 44 superzahl 3
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text eine erfolgsmeldung der
deutschen dressurreiterinnen zum 25 mal
haben sie den europameister titel in der
mannschaftswertung gewonnen bei der em
in hagen setzte olympia siegerin jessica
von bredow werndl einen glänzenden
höhepunkt mit der lehrer holte sie als
einzige aller teilnehmer über 80 prozent
in der turnierwertung und damit gold
gemeinsam mit rekord- europameisterin
isabell werth sowie dorothee schneider
und helen langehanenberg
auf platz zwei und drei großbritannien
und dänemark
so und jetzt ein stück deutsche pop
geschichte deutsch deutsche pop
geschichte seit exakt 30 jahren gibt es
jetzt die prinzen in diesem jahr war ihr
plan 30 jahre 30 städte 30 hits abgesagt
wegen sie wissen schon das ändert aber
nichts daran dass die prinzen mit
bislang fünf millionen konzertbesuchern
zu den absolut erfolgreichsten bands in
diesem land zählen dass sie leipzig
lieben ihre stadt aber stolz darauf sind
wenn ost west west ost bei den fans
keine rolle mehr spielt steffi morenz
[Musik]
zurück zu den wurzeln fünf grenzen auf
dem weg zur thomaskirche es gibt diesen
spruch einmal thomaner immer thomaner
und da ist schon was dran also man fühlt
sich ja schon irgendwie zu hause schon
damals durften sie den westen kennen
lernen waren als kur knaben in der welt
auf tournee ein privileg zu ddr zeiten
das ihren horizont schon damals
erweiterte
[Musik]
wenn wir von west reisen wieder gekommen
sind und im geografieunterricht hatten
oder geschichtsunterricht und die lehrer
uns dann erzählt haben wie es im westen
zu geht irgendwie dann so leise lächeln
gelassen hundertprozentig stimmt das
nicht inzwischen sind sie alle über 50
wollen aber schon damals gewusst haben
ja damals schon gewusst dass wir
irgendwann popstars sein werden
[Musik]
über drei jahrzehnte lang führten sie
hallen und plätze oft ausverkauft
ausgerechnet mit einem ticket für eine
talente show im zdf begann vor 30 jahren
alles ihr talent wurde sofort erkannt
und es begann eine wilde zeit voller
konzerte neue alben und goldener
schallplatten
[Musik]
du musst ein schwein sein
damals wie heute texte die witzig
klingen und dennoch sozialkritisch sind
[Musik]
wie gut sich einzumischen sich darum zu
kümmern was für einer welt lebst und
nicht einfach zu sagen es ist wie es ist
und wir können gar nichts machen können
eine menge machen stellt die prinzen
haben den soundtrack einer ganzen
generation geprägt auf ihrem neuen album
gibt es manch alte songs mit den jungen
gästen sind damit mal wieder in den
charts von null auf platz 2 geschnellt
so ist es jetzt eben das junge dass die
nächste generation ankommt und sagt hey
es ist uns eine ehre zitat würde ich
nicht sagen mit dem prinzen zusammen
musik machen zu dürfen und da ist freut
uns natürlich extrem das hab ich aber
auch jeden tag ja eine ehre mit dem
prinzen zusammen musik machen
leipzig ist noch immer ihre basis und
von hier aus können sie sich gut und
gern noch 30 weitere jahre prinzen pop
vorstellen wir hoffen in zukunft noch
eine weile wir hoffen wir machen noch
eine weile zusammen musik und wir hoffen
dass diese musik noch viele menschen
hören wir haben daran besteht wohl kein
zweifel haben sie sich doch schon mal
die krone der schöpfung aufgesetzt wir
sind
[Musik]
30 jahre die prinzen und damit
verabschieden wir uns für heute nah
sagte mir meldet sich um 0.45 mit
unserem heute-journal update von uns
allen hier beim heute journal einen
angenehm abend ist
[Musik]
ein schokolade und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter in der zweiten nachthälfte
kommt von südwesten her etwas regen auf
das sehen wir hier wies reinzieht
ansonsten gibt es zum nachmittag
kräftige gewitter das hängt mit diesem
tief zusammen ist zwar weiter nach
nordosten aber dessen kaltfront erreicht
uns außerdem gelangt recht warme luft
von süden europas in unsere richtung so
wird es morgen dann recht warm werden in
der nacht gibt es also wolken
verdichtung im südwesten und erste
schauer sind dabei ansonsten klar des
grösstenteils auf und die temperaturen
sinken auf 8 grad richtung vogtland und
18 grad am oberrhein ähnlich mild mit 16
grad ist es ganz im westen deutschlands
morgen gibt es viel sonnenschein vor
allem in den östlichen landesteilen und
im süden richtung rhein und generell im
westen deutschlands bilden sich dann im
nachmittags schauer und gewitter die
sind dann durchaus kräftiger mit
regenmengen von 20 bis 30 liter in
kurzer zeit vor allem der nähe dann der
gewitter ansonsten bleibt es
größtenteils erst einmal trocken bei
höchsten temperaturen von bis zu 28 grad
im nordwesten ansonsten werte aber
zwischen 24 und 27 grad die kommenden
tage weitere schauer und gewitter vor
allem am freitag im norden und im westen
sind dabei 20 bis 27 grad die höchsten
werte samstag ist immer noch ist es
immer noch gewittrig vor allem nach
osten hin am sonntag wird es deutlich
ruhiger und trockner ein schöner abend